what does this night mean and now you're
ready for this performance we're more
excited about the performance than you
are
how am i doing good I'm great yeah you
know your performance tonight with Lady
Gaga is the most anticipated performance
of the night I do believe how is it
I feel really good you know we worked
really hard all week and I just want to
make sure we give people what they want
oh I think you're gonna do that and she
worked with you like in this performance
how is the practice bad I've heard
you've been calm cool and collected
that's what the word out there where did
you directed this thing no it was a
great collaboration with everybody at
the Oscars and Glenn and the Steadicam
operator let's go tonight Tyler's
amazing it was really fun in many ways
this is the end of an incredible journey
what does it meant and what does this
journey meant to you especially with
Gaga in the hope all the folks from my
stars
make it and then have it been received
the way it is your dad looking down a
nice smile I hope so I want to go did
you did you practice busting into your
little girl a little bit
first well we ended the movie below her
room so she was in the nativity knows
for the first six months of her life
yeah that's great they listen to music
or so like never want to hear that sound
drag with the rest of your life like I'm
done with this how did you think that
you did lullabies I think you and house
arena how's the family doing here your
mom's here and house how is she enjoying
this moment my mother's a wreck she's so
nervous yeah oh yeah
[Music]